grace everyone I'm a lot of coming to
you live from VidCon 2017 not actually
live I'm at my hotel room but VidCon is
nearby but really what better time than
Jerry VidCon to talk about quickly
somebody studied journalism a big part
of what I was taught was how to write a
good headline and the importance of a
headline and the importance of also
maintaining factual accuracy in a head
look and I think because of that
perspective that I have my understanding
of the web clickbait is very different
to a lot of people on the internet I
feel like some of the time I will see
something that makes me go like oh good
job writer that is a good headline
good work headlines are difficult I know
and then the comments on that will be
like this is clickbait and a lot of
people are angry and I just get very
confused and feel very out of the loop
it kind of looks like what punishing
people for writing well with how much
the word clickbait is thrown around so I
want to talk about what my definition of
quickly is because it definitely doesn't
exist quickly is basically the same as
the way bait is used in fishing there's
a fish just hanging out and then they
see something that just looks peacefully
like food but they can go bite on to eat
but it's actually a hook that is
incredibly painful
what's a headline to me is a headline
that straight up lies to the audience to
get a click and most oftentimes the body
of text or the video is not at all
reflective of that headline or just
isn't any content really at all like
they try to make money off of the click
and the content was really an optical a
good example I so recently was a
headline that was something along the
lines of fiance losses a bunch of weight
you won't believe what her husband does
when he returns from serving in Iraq so
you go in expecting this heartfelt story
about a woman who's lost a bunch of
weight and you expect reaction images
and foreign off the photos and what you
click through it's actually just an ad
for a weight loss pill that is
completely unrelated to the headline and
literally does not reference it in the
slightest I'm going to try to get me to
click the two aren't even they don't
even overlap totally misleading
thus clickbait another really good one
and I'm going to call have a specific
outlet noble 106.9 is a pretty popular
radio station in Australia and a lot of
the news stories tend to populate
Facebook feed I guess probably because a
lot of my Facebook friends are from
Australian the headline is a Disneyland
with a resort waterpark and helipad set
to open in oz this summer click on the
article and it's not actually about
Disneyland at all it's about some other
theme park entirely that want to outlet
refer to as being the Disneyland of
Victoria and another brand with that and
you know literally called it Disneyland
in the headline that's an example of one
where the headline is still quite bait
because it's incredibly misleading and
intentionally misleading but the body of
the text is still actually a news
article it's not a scam it's not an ad
your counselors click better so for what
is not click bait I think that if
something is accurate
it can't be quickly if the headline is
true and reflects the content no matter
how attractive it is it's not click
there then it's just a headline that
sells the content well which is a
writer's job to do and you know as a
side note we shouldn't be mad at writers
for trying to get clicks of course
people want you to click on the things
they've made so if they like then yeah
we're totally allowed to get mad at that
I was going to use an example from
someone else here but I'm just going to
do it on my own content because I can
speak about my perspective the easiest a
few people accuse me of clickbait when I
upload a video I think the title was my
top 5 games in 2016 and why I'm chatted
for isn't one of them that's literally
what I spoke about in the video top to
bottom
it reflects the content completely
accurately and I want to mention that I
didn't come up with the headline before
making the video I made the video how to
thought that was like ok if I not
mentioned I'm shouted for people going
on why and because I spoke about that
for several minutes put it in the
headline because it's accurate
on another note I've seen people accuse
any sexual content on the Internet as
being clickbait when I totally disagree
it even happens on specifically sex
education shelves and it comes across as
like a form of audience encourage
censorship if someone talks about
something sexual out of genuine interest
or even educational value audiences will
assume they're only talking about the
clicks and that accuse them of clickbait
and kind of stop them from wanting to
make more of that kind of content
because audiences react so negatively to
it do we not want people to make this
kind of content do we want people to
only talk about very boring g-rated
things online because the things that
are good headlines
be bad like what is the angry yelling of
the wood QuickBase even accomplishing on
a video about sex you would be most
welcome to call it clickbait if it was a
thumbnail of a haas make ago and a
headline that was like I had sex with
Rihanna then the video is actually just
like a GTA cutscene of someone getting a
lap dance from a character model that
vaguely looks like Rihanna that would be
quickly I just want to be able to
compliment someone if they write us all
a headline tell them that I like the
headline and not have people assume that
I'm being sarcastic because they're all
calling it quickly even though it's
accurate but hey maybe that's just me
this one time I feel like it maybe is
just me you said it on the internet all
the time but I might actually be alone
alright that is it for me today guys I
have to thank some of my awesome folks
on patreon a day off Eric bought a lot
of Scott Dixon Mexicans allas backs on
and Callie Riggs thank you guys so much
for watching this video and I will see
you guys next time
why